morning the prime minister is facing new
calls for his resignation after pictures
of him were leaked that appeared to show
him partying in downing street uh
transport secretary grant shapz is with
us uh on the program this morning good
morning to you
thanks for joining us have you been
offered a cup of tea i have not but but
uh thank you very much
four bottles of wine two bottles of fizz
bottle of gin eight blurred out people
how do we explain that yeah i mean look
i've talked about this before because as
i've told you my uh dad was in hospital
during this period we thought we'd lost
him in fact we didn't see him for the
best part of four months i've talked
about my you know anger about
uh about that in the past um however i
think these are things that we've known
about the prime minister has said it
shouldn't have happened and he has
apologized and of course the police have
spent their time investigating it as
well so i don't think the fact of the
pictures us seeing them for the first
time changes what the police and sue
grey would have already known
yeah but the prime minister did say that
he thought that everybody was following
the rules
yes and and look i i i don't want to say
otherwise because i'm disappointed to
to to see what happened in downing
street and we know now because the
police have issued um fines uh that um
that that wasn't right and you know but
the prime minister has completely
reformed downing street set up a new
office of the prime minister has a new
permanent secretary
running that so it's completely
reorganized um has apologized which i
think is is very important and of course
it's been thoroughly investigated how
disappointed are you with the prime
minister
well i don't think these things should
have happened but i think it's probably
worth
recalling in context that throughout
this period the prime minister himself
had been seriously ill had a close brush
with coronavirus he lost his mum during
the period he's dealing with the
pandemic
by the looks of things he goes and
thanks somebody who's leaving um raises
a glass to them and you know as i say i
i i
having
like everyone in this country lived
through coronavirus and in many cases
made
enormous sacrifices um don't enjoy um
seeing pictures that suggest anything
else but this is well-covered territory
we've seen this we've known about this
and the only difference is seeing the
photograph sure i mean the problem is
transport secretary that he misled
parliament didn't he no i don't look
like the question is was he down there
partying no clearly not he'd gone by to
to say thanks and raise a glass to a
colleague who was leaving um and you
know
the answer to this of course is that the
police have spent a lot of time with a
lot of people and a lot of resources
crawling over it uh and they've come to
their conclusion as we know he wasn't
fined for that then i understand that
but there's a difference between the
police investigation and what he said in
parliament and if you'll indulge me i
just want to remind our viewers what
happened on the 8th of december uh and
the question at prime minister's
questions um from the labour mp
catherine west who specifically asked
about this event
will the prime minister tell the house
whether there was a party in downing
street on the 13th of november
prime minister
mr speaker no but i'm sure that and
whatever happened uh the guidance was
followed and the rules were followed at
all times
comfortable with that yeah well look at
as i say the he he goes where he's true
he goes he goes down i mean
i see his boxers are in the which which
is his work work boxes so it looks to me
like he goes down on his way uh out of
the office and thanks the the staff from
raises the glass and doesn't in
his mind recognize that as a party and
indeed the police
have looked into this um spent a lot of
time and resources to say and i don't
i'm not i'm not but let me just pick you
up there if i made transportation
because people who were at that event
have been fined
well and and we know from other events
including the the the birthday um yeah
you know event that um some people in
the room were and some people weren't
and the police will have the reason but
i'm not there to double sort of you know
double guess the either the met police
or in fact the durham police who are
looking at different incidents and they
have to look at the evidence along with
sue gray and come to their conclusions
and i know in the case of the police
they have so great i'm not asking about
the police i'm asking about what he said
in parliament when he said there was no
event on the 13th of november what did
he think was happening where are all
these bottles on the table well look i i
think probably what happened is
he's at the end of a busy day he walks
down he says cheers to somebody who's
worked there and walks out and to him
that is not a party but actually of
course we know that there's a final
stage to this which is mps themselves
through the privileges committee will be
looking into what he said to parliament
as well um so we'll we'll we'll even
have i mean this thing has been pretty
well investigated i would say and uh
there will be further investigation so
you won't be sure to further
investigation i get that but there were
more than two people in one room and
there was booze on the table and um
he was there and he said later on in
parliament that nothing happened what
did he think people would do well he
would have been in and out of rooms and
with with lots of people uh who are
working on coronavirus lots of the time
someone's leaving he goes and thanks
them and raises a glass now look i don't
as i said to you um i have personal
reasons for
feeling
uh quite strongly emotional about that
period
of time in the sacrifices that
people were making myself included so
you know i don't seek to defend it nor
does the prime minister in fact is
apologized uh you know i think that the
police sue gray and the privileges
committee are the right places for these
things to be looked into the police have
already done their job as i said i don't
attempt to second-guess their work
whether that's the met police or indeed
the the durham police with the the
leader of the opposition that is the
police's job to look at those things and
make their determinations we have
confirmation this morning that
uh the meeting that took place between
sue gray and the prime minister
yesterday the minister told us that it
was the instigation of sugray then
number 10 told us otherwise we're being
told this morning it's been confirmed
that um
during that meeting the prime minister
asked who grey to drop the report
look i wasn't at the meeting but i know
there were official
officials there the meeting was actually
arranged by officials just on the timing
and logistics of the of the report so uh
beyond that i'm afraid i don't have any
use how would you feel about the
suggestion that the prime minister had
asked for this report to be dropped
given that publicly he said that
he was looking forward to it well look i
haven't seen that uh but what do you
think
it's really important to know
my viewers this morning will think what
do you mean he asked for the report to
be dropped well as i say i i i wasn't in
the room so i don't know that's the
okay what i do know is uh it's perfectly
normal and proper in fact it happened
before sue gray's interim report for
there to be a brief conversation where
they just talk about timing and
logistics of the report exactly what was
discussed i don't know but you know
fortunately and i think this is one of
the great things about this this country
we live in a country where you know
everybody has to stick by the rules when
they don't for example the fixed penalty
notice that we've seen
is issued we have uh proper processes in
place and sue grey uh i know from the
interim report let alone what she may
well say next has identified a number of
shortcomings in number 10 from that
period of time the prime minister's
already picked up on a whole series of
them and made very fundamental reforms
in downing street including a a brand
new office of the prime minister which
we've never had in this country before
to make sure that propriety and ethics
are followed at every turn you talk
about proprietary and ethics
the person that is carrying out what
we're told was an independent report is
called into the office of the prime
minister and said drop the report no
look again i i i wasn't
there i don't know that's the case and
independently confirmed that that
happened well again i haven't heard that
but what i do know is how do you feel
about that but hold on a minute first of
all still with the facts what i do know
is it was officials in number 10 who
arranged for the two of them to have a
brief discussion
but it was a but it was a technical
discussion about timing uh of the report
and a totally normal thing to happen
before a report like this is is
published and quite what they discussed
you seem to have had more information
about the inside of the meeting than
than i do i
the only thing i have to say is that you
know sometimes occasionally things get
reported which are not entirely uh
accurate the civil service were there uh
to make sure that all the correct
processes were followed so i've no
particular reason for concern about the
two of them meeting that's normal it
happened before the interim report and
unless we're you know
casting aspersions on sue grey which i
don't think anyone needs no we're not no
i don't think anyone is i i will have to
wait to hear from sue but i can i i can
assure you sue grey will be completely
uh open and uh she has a fearsome
reputation so i'm sure uh we'll find out
strong women they really get under your
skin don't they um as far as the police
are concerned should they be looking i
mean are you completely comfortable that
that there were no more fines to the
prime minister given that somebody who
was actually at the same event that the
prime minister was out saying um that
they felt that it was completely unfair
i can't work out why he's not been fined
and other people have the mets are
shambled
well look i'm not here to criticize the
the met they have a job to do they threw
in loads of resources to this a lot of
people have spent a fortune i don't
think you were asking me about it last
time i was on i've spent a a fortunately
and have turned over all of the evidence
uh that that they had enormous access to
so i'm not here to sort of second-guess
did the police get this right or wrong
as i say you know the police have a
difficult job to do in all these
circumstances whether it's uh the prime
minister uh you know um during the the
you know holding a glass up to say
cheers to somebody who's who's leaving
uh and whether he was therefore just
dropping by to move on uh or you know
still against the law at the time well i
was gonna say in the case of the um of
the
birthday uh wishes uh event some people
seem to have received fines and some
didn't i don't know why and similarly
we've got this police investigation of
the leader of the opposition and the
deputy leader of the opposition up in
durham and i don't seek to second-guess
what they're doing either i think we
have to let the police in this country
who are entirely independent get on with
their job okay so just before we move on
because i want to ask you about ukraine
you're completely comfortable about that
photographs on the front page of the
paper look i'm not i've already told you
i couldn't see my own dad for a long
period of time because we were obeying
the rules but i also accept that the
prime minister has long since uh
apologized has made fundamental reforms
in number 10 and i've no doubt if he had
his time again
would not have
would not have dropped by to say thank
you to a member of staff leaving so no
i'm not but it is
it is what it is uh and we're about to
talk about ukraine and there are you
know potential for industrial action on
our railways many other things that the
country does need to get let's move on
to ukraine what are we doing to try to
get this grain out of odessa i'm very
concerned about it i met with my
opposite number alexander kubrickov last
week who's the infrastructure transport
secretary of state in ukraine i met with
him in germany last week and we were
discussing details which i i can't go
into but about how infrastructure could
be in place to ensure that grain leaves
i'm specifically concerned with the
situation in ukraine we've seen this
barbaric invasion by putin what really
worries me is
we've seen many lives lost in ukraine
we could see even more lives lost in
other places uh in the world through uh
grain and food shortages which could be
even greater than the lives lost in the
war directly so we do need to find
solutions to getting this are we going
to try and organize safe passage well
we're looking at all the different
options and as i don't want to go into
detail with my conversation with uh
kubrickov but uh there are lots of
different potential ways to get grain
and other goods out of the country and
the goods into the country as well i
think it's absolutely essential
that we do otherwise there could be a
lot of
hunger indeed even famine
which could dwarf the numbers involved
in the war itself some of the papers
this morning suggesting that we may send
um military ships down there in order to
try to organize that safe passage you
you will have seen the spectation i
can't go into specific detail there are
a lot of complexities to this including
mind waters uh in the near odessa port
uh
clearly uh the situation with russia and
putin and their
their approach to this could make that
very difficult uh but but as i say the
big top line is
it's hard to um overestimate the extent
to which ukraine was and is the bread
basket of the world actually their flag
which is the the blue on top of the sky
and the yellow underneath is actually
the the grain or the corn or the wheat
is that it's the fields um and and it's
because they are such a big producer of
of of the world's food so it is
important that we uh seek to help them
find ways to get it out closer to home
if we have a rail strike are we going to
prioritize freight trains so that there
is still food on the shelves yes we'll
do exactly that but look i i don't i
love the railways and i know the people
who work on them do as well i don't want
to see
strikes on our railways i think this is
very very premature
i noticed that the the unions were
saying it's because they want their pay
on frozen it is going to be on frozen no
one's talking about pay staying where it
was we do have to balance
rail workers with the needs of doctors
and nurses and teachers and the rest of
the public service
and so it is important that we get that
balance right
the taxpayer has put in 16 billion
pounds that's 600 pounds per family
household whether you use the trains or
not and we've done that to keep the
trains running no one lost their jobs
during coronavirus but we do need to
reform our railways so i'm looking to to
to get this resolved i want the unions
to do that as well i urge them not to
call strikes i think it will be
completely counterproductive to a
railway which frankly is on life support
and that could give it a heart attack
but just to confirm that that you will
prioritize freight trains if necessary
correct yeah okay so that the shut we
don't need to worry about uh empty
shells no we'll make sure that we get
because freight and distribution and the
supply chain are absolutely critical and
talking about um food from ukraine you
know making sure that distribution both
of energy and food nationally takes
place is very important and we'll of
course we'll prioritize that but i think
it's important to to recognize you know
our railways can't carry on we've lost a
quarter of our passengers and a quarter
of the income and actually they haven't
been reformed for many many uh years i
want to build up a bigger railway uh
ultimately but i need to work in
cooperation with the
unions on that and and i really hope
that they'll do that rather than as i
say essentially just as the railways are
trying to recover uh give it a heart
attack we are out of time but i throw
enough brick bats at you a bouquet um in
the form of a rhode haulier who i spoke
to in wigan last week and he said it's
got much better for royal haulage now
and there aren't the challenges that
they had before so next time grant chaps
is on your program can you tell him so
there you go thank you we took 33
measures to try to help that market and
get uh fresh let's work it again i'm
pleased to hear that it's good to talk
to you thanks very much